[Applause]
[Music]
again that is not my body they put my
head
that I don't know why hip gamine
creature not you you don't know who that
is
guys is that someone who works here who
is that you don't know yeah the
producers I don't know he's just making
restaurant reservations we we don't know
her name
yeah she's a mystery lady I could have I
would have come downstairs and put on a
blue shirt khakis and taking that but no
they didn't even ask me and then they
found someone who's I think eating for
calories in their lifetime but anyway
let's get back to the premise which is
that little button that you push on the
TV remote that tells you what you're
gonna watch and then it's called what
are we watching for example I was
watching bar rescue
and then I hit the button and it said
human bazooka screams at a failing dive
bar until it morphs into a failing
sports bar Marlin was watching the show
Marlin and then I hit the button and it
said another member of the Wayans family
has granted his own TV show in
accordance with the blood pack their
grandmother made with the devil 27 years
ago
I wish my grandma had done that yeah
that's what we got in Shark Tank I was
watching shark tank yeah then I hit the
button and it said in tonight's episode
the real estate lady buys her fourth
vibrator company house watching diners
drive-ins and dives
yeah then I hit the button and it said
human vape pen invades people's space
until they feed him I'm told he's a very
nice man yeah all right whatever the
mist I was watching the show the mist
yeah it's watching the mist and I hit a
button you think fog is for [ __ ] but
rain seems a tad extreme then sit down
and strap in because this is the show
for you
[Applause]
yeah yeah and yes episode he becomes
moist
I was watching Dancing with the Stars
sure yeah yeah and then I hit the button
and it said the phone call every fading
superstar dreads yeah yeah my audience
with odd that that was too mean nothing
dear daughter saw dark whisper moon they
really love Nick Lachey and hey let's go
Pawn Stars
I was watching Pawn Stars yeah yeah cuz
that's what you do and then I hit the
button when you first heard the title
you knew it was a play on porn stars but
you've completely forgotten that over
the years isn't it funny how the brain
works it is
I was watching this show wall burgers
wall burgers yeah and then hit the
button a bunch of pinkish lumps of meat
cook hamburgers
good boy they're gonna they're gonna
kick the [ __ ] out of me
it's a good thing we never run into
celebrity oh yeah right I go back to
Boston and it's huge
and finally guy's grocery games oh boy
yeah and then I hit they didn't know
what's going on then I hit the button
and it said clean-up on Aisle this show
sucks it's the damn info button right
now yeah who the hell are we to pass
judgment on any other show you know we
had guys in diapers and sunburns and
we're here like
[Applause]
you